hi everybody this is peter cooper from
the ncbi
uh and welcome to today's webinar i'm
going to let cooper park take it away
and talk about the viewers and uploading
data
awesome thanks peter as you've already
heard and you probably already knew from
registering today
uh the talk today is about uploading and
viewing your data in genomic context
with
ncbi and our data viewers
so here's just a little brief overview
of what we'll be covering today
first of all i'll talk about some of the
different genome browsers and cvi offers
and then discuss a little bit about why
you may want to use one over another
then i'll talk a little bit about the
types of data that you can visualize in
these browsers
and which files you're going to need to
have in order to do that
and then finally i'll end the talk with
a quick live demonstration of uploading
some data into one of our browsers
and talk about some of the way you can
compare this against data
that's already provided by ncbi and how
to share all of those results with your
colleagues
so we'll kick it off by talking about
which kind of tools ncbi can offer for
you
the first one today is called the
sequence viewer sometimes we just
abbreviate that as
sv the sequence viewer is a web-based
visualization tool that lets you
investigate different gene
and nucleotide records stored at ncbi
and although you can view almost any
record in gene or nucleotide using the
sequence viewer
this tool is really the best option for
those of you that are interested in
visualizing bacterial
viral or archaeal sequences now the
sequence viewer itself is actually the
backbone of
all other ncbi genome viewers for
example during the live demonstration
today
i'll be using a different tool um which
i'll be talking about in a few moments
but in reality almost all of the
features in that demonstration are
really built inside sequence viewer
so even after this talk if you find
yourself using a different visualization
tool
the odds are pretty good that you'll be
comfortable with using the sequence
viewer anyway
and similarly if you are already coming
into this with some experience
using the sequence viewer then moving
into some of these other tools i'll talk
about next should actually be pretty
easy for you
uh the next tool is the genome workbench
which at its core is really like a local
copy of the sequence viewer which you
can by nature of being a local copy
download to your own computer and use
however it's also a lot more than just
that
it also provides several other packages
that you can use to help
give yourself a one stop shop for a
complete analysis of your data
as well as analyzing other sequences
stored within ncbi
for example the workbench offers many
different graphical views
including several for viewing multiple
sequences at a time
like multiple sequence alignment viewers
and a phylogenetic tree viewer
or you can even view individual
sequences like exploring their feature
tables and seeing all their annotations
and even just some generic views like
exploring data tables or just sequence
and text
genome workbench also offers several
analytic tools like blast or maft so you
can actually generate some of the data
that you intended visual
intend to visualize in gd in genome
workbench
and another popular feature is actually
the submission pipeline that is built
into the workbench so that you can
prepare
and submit your sequences all from the
same ui
and finally just because i enjoy using
them i'll also point out that the
workbench also offers a phylogenetic
tree building software
so that you can make and visualize your
phylogenetic tree all in one tool
now the last genome viewer we're going
to talk about today is the genome data
viewer
which is often just abbreviated as gdv
and that's how i'll be referring to it
from now on
uh gdb is another web-based similar tool
similar to sequence viewer but it's
specifically designed to explore
annotated eukaryotic sequences stored in
ncbi
so while the sequence viewer is really
the backbone of gdv
therefore you get all of the same tools
and techniques to analyze sequences
gdv is also providing additional
features called widgets
which can offer you the ability to do a
more detailed exploration of those
curated sequences that gdv is designed
for
so now you have an idea of which kind of
tools we actually offer to view your
genomic data
but even after you've picked the right
tool you still might be a little bit
confused about what kind of data you
actually can visualize so let's talk
about that for a minute
um this image is a cropped panel of the
sequence or of the configure panel and
sequence viewer
which you'll use to add different data
in the form of tracks which i'll talk
about in a minute
but this first tab the tracks tab
is basically the source of where all of
the ncbi provided
provided data sets are so that you can
compare
this ncbi provided data to your own data
after you have it uploaded next to that
tab let me back up so you can see it is
the custom data tab
where you can add your data through
several different methods
the first of which you can actually
import blast results and primer blast
results
directly into the viewer so that you can
see where those results align to your
reference sequence
and in fact these these sequence viewers
also provide the ability to build those
splash
searches directly from the viewer so you
can generate that data
and visualize it all in one place of
course we have the more traditional file
upload
option available as well you can use
this option to import any of the many
different file formats that are
supported by these viewers
including things like bed files gfs asn
files and more and i'll talk about
during the demonstration how to find
what other supported file formats are
available
however as many of you are probably
aware some data types just require
multiple files to view
or some data files are just so massive
that you need to store them on some repo
remote repository files like this might
be like a bam
file or a vcf file the sequence viewers
also provide the ability to upload those
files by streaming them to the sequence
viewer using the remote files option
so as long as these files are publicly
available in like an ftp
page or a github page or even like a
cloud bucket
you should be able to import that file
into our sequence viewers without having
to get it to your
local machine now these last three
settings are a little more
self-explanatory so i'll move them move
through them more quickly
the alignment option is reserved for
uploading an alignment file from your
computer
the url option lets you upload a file
from a url so it's kind of like the
remote files but it's more designed for
those beds and gff files
that you just might happen to have
stored online as well and lastly you can
even just copy and paste the text from
any of our accepted file formats and
paste them into the sequence viewer
and have it uploaded that way and
finally before we go on to this live
demonstration i will quickly mention
that
there are many different types of data
tracks that you can view in our genome
browsers as
you could probably gather from all of
the different file formats that we
accept
well this is a list from our help
documentation of the different tracks
that are available
and i really encourage you to visit the
link that you can see in this box here
after the talk so that you can see
exactly which features are provided for
each track
now in the upcoming demo i will be
mentioning a few of these different
tracks
but i just want to emphasize that
between the different file formats that
are available and the different types of
tracks
hopefully you can appreciate that there
are just a lot of different types of
data that you can visualize all at once
using these genome browsers
so now we're going to move on to the
live demonstration for today
uh this demo is centered around a bbs 9
gene
which i'll talk a little bit about the
background in a moment
and these are just some of the
objectives that we're going to tackle in
the live demonstration
uh we'll give you a pretty general over
introduction of the capabilities of gdv
remember that's the genome data viewer
and the sequence viewer in general
including how to remotely add your data
to gev
how to configure ncbi provided data
and how to run primer blast and
visualize its results
and then finally how we can share that
final view and all of those results
with your colleagues so i'm going to
back out of my slides for a minute and
open up my web browser there we go
hopefully everybody can see that okay
okay so the very first thing we need to
do is actually get
to the genome data viewer and so the
easiest way to do that honestly is to
just
google it works out pretty well you see
the link come up right up at the top
and so we can click it and we jump over
to the genome data viewer or gdv home
page
now once we get to this home page we'll
see two little sections the first is
this phylogenetic tree looking thing
which we can use to select our organism
of interest
or if you don't see it readily available
here and you don't want to dig through
some of the like expansion buttons
you can just use the search bar up at
the top and type in your organism to see
if we have it available
right now we have about just over 12 or
1230 assemblies that you can use in
genome data viewer right now
but that number is constantly increasing
anyway once you have your organism
selected which in my case i'll be using
human
you can use this panel on the right to
customize exactly what data you want
to genome data viewer to load at the
beginning
so for example we can use this drop down
menu here
to select the correct assembly we want
which i'm okay with the current assembly
so we'll just leave that as is
if you wanted and you were thinking you
would be a little exploratory
you can use these chromosome buttons
down here at the bottom to load in a
specific chromosome
or what i'll do today is i can just use
the search bar here to type
in the actual gene i'm interested in
exploring which is that vbs9 gene
so i can type it in here and then hit
the search button to load in gv
now i already have the page loaded over
here so i won't hit enter but
this is what the page will look like
once you've hit enter on that
that feature search so when you first
arrive to this viewer page
you'll see several panels of data that
have all been kind of stacked on top of
each other
now each of these panels is called a
track and these are where your data
actually get visualized and when you
first load your assembly gdv
is going to have a few default tracks
loaded for you
but the reality is is you'll probably
want to change them
so to remove the unnecessary tracks from
the viewer you can use this little red x
button in the top right corner
and just remove the tracks so i'm going
to go ahead and delete
all of these extra tracks but i'm going
to go ahead and keep this ncbi
annotation released just so that i can
see where the genes lie on the sequence
you can also customize the tracks that
are available by going to that configure
panel that i talked about in the slides
so if we click on this little configure
tracks button here we can see this page
that looks
almost similar to the screenshot
and here we can see the tracks that are
currently active we have the sequence
track which is represented as this
little blue bar in the background here
and then we have that ncbi annotation
release
which is the track i was emphasizing
earlier
now this is okay for now i'm going to
leave this page up but uh so i can show
you how we can also add some other
data tracks but first let's talk about
the data that i'm actually going to add
today
i have some amplicon sequence read data
from this patient who is diagnosed with
a developmental disorder called barde
beetle syndrome
and i've aligned that patient's sequence
reads
uh to this human reference genome and
you may have caught the context for this
already by the gene name i looked at
but structural variations to this bbs9
gene have actually been implicated as
the causal agent
in this bbs diagnosis so my plan is to
use gdv
to visualize the alignment of my
amplicon sequence reads
to this bbs9 reference sequence and then
see if there are any sort of structural
variations in the patient's gene
that can help confirm this diagnosis
that they got
and then on top of that i'll also try
and use ncbi's dbvar data to help
determine whether any variation i do
find
has already been cataloged in ncbi so
that i can hopefully get some more
information about it
so to add my own data to the viewer i'm
going to use this configure panel and go
over to the custom data tab
and then because the file i want to let
load in is a bam file
i'm going to use the remote files option
now i have that bam file saved in a
cloud bucket already online
so i'm just going to copy the link that
i have for it and paste the url here
and then just as an optional bonus i'm
going to name my track so it's easier to
see
i'll just call it my data for now and
then when i click configure
and then click yes to upload the
external data we'll give it a couple of
seconds
and we see a new track added into the
sequence viewer with my data
imported now the file that i just
uploaded is shown in what's called a
pileup
view this view is basically a very long
histogram
where the tall peaks in that histogram
represent regions of the assembly
that have lots of coverage from my
sequencing data
and the view right now is looking a
little bit condensed just because the
sequences i have
only seem to align to this first little
chunk of the bvs9 gene
and apparently some rp9 gene and that's
okay so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to use this little coordinate
plane up at the top
to highlight that region where my
sequences are aligned
and then i'm going to use the pop-up
menu to click zoom on range
to zoom in on that region now all track
data
has a legend associated with it to help
you understand what you're actually
looking at
and you can find these legends using the
little question mark button in the
right corner of the sequence viewer we
click that and then click legends
it'll open up a new tab with the help
documentation
of all of the possible track views
now this should probably even look
familiar to you if you're watching the
slides this is that screenshot i have
showing all of the different track views
and if we scroll down you can see all of
the details for the different tracks
so again you can use this information to
really help you understand what you're
looking at
in each of the tracks you add well this
pile up view
basically looks like it has three colors
and from the legend will
i can tell you that the gray section of
the view
represents a solid alignment between my
data and this
the reference sequence the little spots
of red in that gray
represent mismatches in that alignment
and then this big block of black that
runs across
most of the sequence alignment is
actually a gap between my data
and the alignment well it's probably not
a surprise to most of you that a giant
gap
covering a gene and a half is probably
significant in the diagnosis of a
potential clinical disorder
so we're going to try and use some ncbi
track data to help make sense of that
finding
so again i'm going to go back and open
up that little configure panel
or configure page and this time i'm
going to go down to the variation tab
in the tracks panel and scroll
almost all the way to the very bottom
to add in this dbvar pathogenic clinical
structural variance
when i click configure here it's going
to add a third track that shows all of
the structural variants in dbvar
that are associated with this region and
based on the legend we know that some of
these variants that are blue
are based on insertions and the red ones
are based on deletions
so because gaps in an alignment are
generally most easily explained by
deletions
i can narrow down my results and start
looking through these red
structural variants to see if any of
them may be interesting
now most of these variants extend well
beyond the region that i sequenced here
which makes it harder for me to know
whether or not my sequenced region is
actually contributing to the pathogenic
interpretation that these variants are
implicated in
however at the bottom of this track we
see this little variant here
uh that does seem to fit nicely in the
deleted region
so we're going to try and investigate
this one a little further
if we click on the variation itself
it'll draw these nice little tracer
lines up and down the rest of my tracks
to help give me a sense of where what
other features in the other tracks
fit within the boundaries of that
variant and so it looks
like we have a few exons within the bbs9
gene which are nicely encompassed in
this variant
but we can confirm whether or not those
are exons by using
this exon navigator in this blue bar up
at the top here
so we can look here and see that the
gene selected for this navigator is the
vbs9 gene which is what we want
and then we can use these little bubbles
here uh to
identify the specific exons within that
gene
so when you highlight over the bubble it
will if you can i can't
move my mouse to point it out otherwise
it'll lose the region but you can see
that it highlights a part of
or highlights the first exon in that
gene and as we move across the other
bubbles
it highlights the other exons down the
gene so by highlighting over them we can
see that exon 2
3 and 4 happen to fall in line within
the structural variant
and if we clicked on any of these
bubbles it would actually
zoom in on that exon so we could get a
closer look
now another way that we can investigate
this variant is actually just by
hovering over the variant
and then moving down to this db bar link
here at the bottom and clicking it
and it'll open up a new panel which is
actually the dbvar page for that variant
and then we can explore all sorts of
information that we want for that
variant
and in fact if we move over to the
clinical assertions page
we can see the phenotype does in fact
suggest that this variant is implicated
in the barde beetle syndrome
which means that if we're looking at
this giant alignment here perhaps this
region is the most important part of
this deletion
not for example the loss of this rp9
gene
so that's great and it looks like we've
discovered some good clinical
information that probably warrants some
future investigation
but let's say we want to do some
targeted sequencing of this region
whether to sequence some additional
patients or maybe
the family members of this patient for
example well we can actually design
primers to sequence in this region
directly from
the sequence viewer itself and to do
that
we can just use this coordinate plane
again to highlight the region
that we want to design primers for so
i'll just connect those two little
tracer lines again
and then with the pop-up menu we can
just click this primer blast selection
button
this will open up a new tab and it's
preset all of the settings we're
interested in so that we can design
primers for that region
so once i have all the settings in case
there's any settings you even want to
adjust you can change them up as
necessary
and then click the get primers button to
run primer blast
now i've already run that for the sake
of time so what instead i can do
is come over to this user data and track
hubs widget on the right
and using this little pull down menu we
can click the primer pairs
track for the primer blast job that i
ran previously
and it will just go ahead and load in
that track and show us all of the top
hip primers
for this region now unfortunately it
doesn't look like there are any primers
that nicely cover the entire region
but maybe with some other investigation
we can decide that one or
any set of these primers would maybe be
the best option for us so
that's basically all of the features
that i wanted to show off in
gdv today but i'm going to finish off
with just talking about how to share
this view once you've got it
optimized how you want it and there are
a few different ways that you can share
this view
with other people perhaps the easiest
way is to just navigate up to the top
here with this share
page share this page button and when you
click it it'll generate a url that you
can share with your colleagues so that
they can come back to this exact same
view and even
customize it further if they want to do
some more investigations
however i will note that this link is
only good for about 90 days so just keep
that in mind as you are
exploring your data set and sharing it
around
you can get to a similar link by using
that question mark that we used to go to
the legends help desk
or help desk help page
but instead we can click on this link to
view button here
and when you click that it will generate
a longer
url that you can also send which will
generate the same view
or it has an abbreviated go usa url here
that you can send
however the real reason i brought you
over to this page is for this code right
here which allows you to embed the image
into your own web browser or a web page
and there is a lot of instructions on
how to do that in the sequence viewer
documentation so i won't go into it in
detail here
but it is a really neat feature that you
can use for
any number of reasons honestly and then
lastly if you just need it as a nice
clean pdf or an svg file
you can use this download button on the
same toolbar navigate to the printer
friendly pdf svg option
and there you get a list of settings
that you can set to save as a pdf
or svg file
so that is it for the live demonstration
let me navigate back
to the slides for a second and i'll just
quickly touch on that there are a few
other viewers besides these genome
viewers today that you may find useful
for your research
uh one of them is the multiple sequence
alignment viewer which is a great tool
for well viewing multiple sequence
alignments
and it's actually undergone many updates
over the last year or so
so that there are many new features that
should probably appeal to those of you
that like working with the line
sequences regularly
and you can expect a webinar in the near
future that will hopefully
touch on a lot of those features for you
and give you a sense of how to use them
however there's also lots of help
documentation of that link
that you can use if you want to get a
head start we also do have the tree
viewer if you need to investigate a
phylogenetic
tree however i'll also emphasize that if
you need to the service is also offered
by the genome workbench
and finally i would like to just ask
everybody to take this very quick
three-question multiple choice survey
regarding a new potential viewer that
we're interested in developing
i promise this will be very brief we'll
only let each question run for about a
minute
but i encourage you to share your
thoughts with this poll and if you'd
like
please expand on that answer in the chat
if you feel like you'd like
to so let me back out and launch this
first
question
we'll go ahead and take a look at those
results really quick it looks like about
57 percent
or a 43 of you do you do analyze
eukaryotic assemblies that aren't
annotated by refseq
whereas surprisingly a majority of you
seem like you don't that's that's
interesting
all right here comes the second question
are you interested in comparing multiple
assemblies
at the same time in a visualization
tools that's something that would be
helpful to you
let's take a look again it looks like
overwhelmingly the majority of you
do like to compare different assemblies
although it seems to be
uh both same species and different
species
interests that's just good to know
personally i'm a same species guy but
it's cool to see that there's an appeal
for both
all right the final question here it
comes
if you would like to compare multiple
assemblies in a viewer
what are you most interested in learning
about
again it looks like the majority of
people are interested in just about any
feature they can get their hands on and
that's good to know we like providing as
many features as we can
and so with that let me just bring this
back up for you all
thank you for answering the polls
everybody's information is extremely
valuable and very helpful to us
but more importantly thank you all for
attending the talk today at all um if
you'd like to start playing around with
any of these different genome browsers
just talked about today
you can follow the links at the top of
the slide or you can just google the
tool's name and it should come right up
uh we also encourage you to reach out to
us on your favorite platform be it
twitter
facebook linkedin you name it and uh
share with us any feedback or
suggestions you have to improve these
services or
even expand on the answers you provided
in the poll just a minute ago
and of course you can always email us at
info ncbi.nlm.nih.gov
with any of your questions or concerns
that you might have and we'll make sure
we get those addressed
but at this point i think we can go
ahead and open up the floor to some
questions
um i have a question actually uh cooper
when you showed that
the view of that that sort of deletion
that was there
there's a way you can do you know how to
get it so you can you could you could
get so your primers bind outside that
region
i did not know how to do that but i'm
interested definitely
so what you can do is you know just zoom
into that area so that you're outside
the region that you're
interested in select it and then send
that region to primer blast not just
that but get the selection outside of it
and you can also adjust
like just zoom out here further so that
then you have
you can send that um primer blast
selection and then you can
then if you want to you can specify in
the forward and reverse
boxes there you know exactly where you
want the primers to bind
yeah because that's a reasonable thing
to do so you could you could perhaps get
some primers that would
expand that entire uh region it might be
pretty big though i'm not sure how large
it is it's pretty big
but you know that's that's a way where
you can sort of set the primers to
find where you want them to go oh great
that's good to know
yeah hi my name is sanjita rangwala
and i am the product owner of like these
products that
have that you've been showing and i
wanted to give you another
tip that like we don't people don't use
very much but i think it'll work
you can actually select two different
ranges here and i think you can send
them to primer blast and maybe
uh cooper can can try that out oh wow
i didn't know you could i didn't know
you could do that either
what you can do is uh i think if you
just use like shift to highlight like a
region
yeah that's good okay
and then use like control i think then
i think if you use then like move your
mouse over to another region
and then use ctrl shift or it controls i
like
to highlight that now you've selected
two regions then go to
try going to primary blast oh
interesting yeah
so it actually gives you the forward and
the reverse that's a great
tip i like that now that is very
very cool so you need to use control to
highlight the second region
and you can just use click and drag to
highlight the first one yeah that's a
great tip i'll uh
make sure i get a supplement in my demo
script so that people have that tip
logged in there
you know i keep forgetting about that
too we have so many little
things in here and so you reminded me to
check and i was like i think that works
okay well i i don't see any other
questions
someone did ask about how to format a
blast database and
wayne answered that one which isn't
directly relevant to this
particular webinar but you can find out
more about that
on our health documents for blast also
someone asked about online training
cooper can you show your help
slide again so i just wanted to
make sure everybody knows that we have
one of the one of the best places to go
i think to keep up with to get
information about
you know announcements about like say
webinars like this one
would be our blog which is the ncbi
insights blog which is listed there
on this slide in
cbinsight.ncbi.nlm.nih.gov
you can also follow us on twitter or
facebook or linkedin and we announce
whenever we have a webinar like this on
there so that's a good way to keep up
with what
uh online events we have available
well if there are no further questions
then i think
we'll go ahead and end the webinar thank
you very much cooper and thanks
everybody for coming